it will stop raining in the Carolinas
today but the remains of hurricane
Florence are still creating danger
Florence spun off a tornado that killed
at least one person in Virginia
yesterday when a warehouse collapsed
other buildings had their roofs torn off
that storm system is now dumping rain on
the Northeast several rivers in North
Carolina are still rising causing new
flooding the death toll from Florence
nearly doubled yesterday reaching at
least 32 DeMarco Morgan is in downtown
Fayetteville North Carolina which is
mostly under water DeMarco good morning
Norah good morning to you we have been
watching the big Cape Fear River right
here just to basically see where and
when it will crust you can see the water
is already at the bottom of the bridge
this is exactly where it was during
Hurricane Matthew but let's take a look
at this from a different angle you can
see the railroad bridge there the water
is already touching it and it's causing
a log jam so it's safe to say that
Florence may be gone but this community
is not out of harm's way just yet the
Cape Fear River is bringing just that to
the communities near it fear some areas
have not seen the worst flooding yet
constant rain from Hurricane Florence
caused rivers and creeks in the
Carolinas to swell flooding homes and
businesses as the rivers crest flooding
is only expected to get worse I think
people are getting complacent that's
dangerous
Brendan Plotnik is worried about the
caper Rivers crest that's a lot of water
and that waters got to go somewhere
rescues continued Monday through North
Carolina crews used boats to help
evacuate people in Lumberton trapped by
floodwaters
I thought we were okay until this
tonight when the water just kept coming
up and up the lumber river in Lumberton
is cresting and will not go below major
flood stage until at least next week our
biggest threat here in this area is the
lumber river rising we've wrote along
Monday with Pembroke police rescue
commander Matthew Locklear it was the
lumber of her that caused all of the
massive flooding during Hurricane
Matthews that's another reason for
concern right exactly as the water rises
so does Florence's death toll I was
holding his hand trying to hold him days
ELISA 14 month old son Caden Lee Welch
was killed after being swept away by
rushing floodwaters in Union County
Sunday night Kayden's body was recovered
Monday I did everything I could for the
moment I was pregnant in the moment to
this moment I lost him I did everything
I could as a parent to save him didn't
protect him not just awful a tough time
for the people who call these states
here in this area home now Gail we can
tell you this that the river is expected
to crest at nearly 62 feet and will not
go below flood stage until Saturday but
my heart breaks for that mom there yeah
it really does you know she really tells
the story but DeMarco it's so good to
see that you're not standing in the rain
hopefully things will get a lot better
for the people there it is thank you
very much